Hey folks. It’s precon review time! I’m going
to be critiquing the Eternal Might precon for
Aetherdrift, and offering some potential points of
improvement. The last two precons I’ve discussed
have impressed me with their construction, seeming
surprisingly streamlined in their functionality,
and easily upgradeable into a quite decent magic
deck. It’s actually been a bit disappointing,
what am I supposed to do aside from say “this
is pretty good, cut these five bad cards and
it’ll be even better.” Thankfully, that’s not
a problem with this precon. Though containing
good card quality, lots of nice assorted
zombie cards, and some nice attention to
detail in terms of aesthetics, in terms of
construction this deck is a hot mess express,
a disgusting mishmash of conflicting gameplans
and synergistic dead-ends, and I’m excited to
tackle it. To start with, though, let’s talk
about what this deck is trying to accomplish.
The commander of this deck is Temmet, a five mana
4/4 in Esper colors with vigilance and menace,
as well as the following text: “Whenever you
attack, draw a card, then discard a card.
Whenever you draw a card, zombies you control
get +1/+1 until end of turn.” So, on the surface,
this is a card that rewards token zombies or
otherwise wide boards of zombies, and also a
card that rewards big draw that happens before the
combat damage step in a turn. Simple effect, but
there are a lot of implied features of this card
we should keep in mind. To be maximally effective,
Temmet wants a large board of zombies to attack
with as well as a large draw spell to amp up
the buff it grants, and it’s also a thing that is
likely going to be a removal magnet if we have a
large board since it can threaten a lot of damage.
Importantly, this means that the deck will want a
lot of mana to both pay the casting cost and also
either draw some cards or hold up mana to protect
it. Looking at the rest of the deck, some parts
of it reflect these specific needs. There are
eight cards that create small zombie tokens and
three army generators, cards that create or add
counters to a singular growing zombie token, and
there are also a handful of cards that create 4/4
zombie tokens as well. The deck also contains
a healthy 9 ramp spells to help bolster it up
to larger quantities of mana. From there, the deck
also has a large number of zombie creatures in it,
which range from cards that drain opponents to
lords to draw spells and beyond. An interesting
additional package in the deck is the discard
package—the alternate commander for this deck is
Hashaton, Scarab’s Fist which can allow a player
to make 4/4 zombie copies of discarded creatures,
and the deck also contains a handful of other
discard payoffs. The amount of discard in the
deck isn’t wildly large, though, consisting of
five or six cards that allow you to discard plus
a handful of cycling cards. There’s also
a light graveyard package to go along with
this. Rounding out the deck, we have a pretty
average number of removal spells. Overall,
this deck looks to be looking to create a
wide board of zombies and utilize its cute
discard and graveyard subthemes, and swing
in at opponents with a Temmet-buffed board.
I obviously pre-empted my overall thoughts on
this deck a bit, but I’ll start with what I like
about what’s happening here. As I said, it has a
larger than average ramp suite for an Esper deck,
which I think is appropriate for this gameplan.
Crowded Crypt and Bontu’s Monument both stand
out as fun ramp options with a lot of
utility in this deck, offering token
production and drain respectively. This deck
also contains some number of token producers,
and some of these are pretty good—I like the ones
that make 1/1 white zombie tokens, and On Wing’s
Of Gold’s flying + anthem effect is good enough
to make the card seem worthwhile even though this
isn’t a deck with a super heavy graveyard
theme, at least by zombie deck standards.
The manabase here is excellent—really robust
symbol counts even with a couple great colorless
utility lands, and a moderately high but not
overwhelming tapland density that also gives
players room to gradually update taplands
with better untapped duals. There are also
some number of cards that slot in elegantly to
this deck—Forgotten Creation pairs perfectly
with both Temmet and Hashaton, as do the newly
printed Prophet of the Scarab and Rhet-Tomb
Mystic. There are also gestures at a number
of packages that could exist—a couple Impact
Tremors style cards paired with the deck’s
tokens package, and a selection of different
graveyard and discard enablers and payoffs to give
a sampling platter of what that could look like.
That’s the most generous way to view this deck
in my mind—it’s a sample of possible gameplans,
and/or a toolbox of possible implements
for beginning the journey of building them.
So what about this as a deck that’s trying
to play a game of Magic: the Gathering? Well,
it’s a bit disappointing. Hashaton has gotten a
lot of attention as an undeniably cool secondary
commander, but it doesn’t even really work as a
secondary commander—this deck just doesn’t have
enough discard to consistently enable Hashaton’s
ability. With Hashaton in the 99 you at least
have the consistent discard effect of Temmet, but
he’s also a five mana card with an overrun-esque
ability, so trusting him to stick around as
an engine is highly optimistic. This lack
of discard likewise stands out in the case for
other discard payoffs such as Lazotep Chancellor
and Archfiend of Ifnir, though those at least get
triggered by the deck’s cycling lands. The deck’s
graveyard package is another thing that stands
out—it’s not massive but it is decidedly present,
as you’d expect with a zombie deck. This
deck is kinda thin on ways to enable it,
though—most zombie decks would be using sacrifice
abilities in addition to discard, and while this
deck does have the sorts of payoffs when creatures
die that those decks tend to have, it’s almost
entirely lacking in ways to sacrifice creatures.
The result is that this deck really lacks a
lot of what might give a zombie deck a sense of
mechanical identity, its disjointedness causing
both play pattern issue—when disparate synergy
packages don’t line up—and vibes issues—when it
just plays like a generic blob of typal midrange
gameplay instead of, you know, like a zombie deck.
Okay, so I obviously have issues with this deck’s
handling of some traditional key zombie subthemes,
but let’s set that aside. This is a precon,
this is meant to be a toolbox and/or a sampling
platter, we can give it some slack. Does this
deck at least hold up in supporting Temmet as
a commander? Are we forging an alternative zombie
playstyle here? In some ways the answer to that is
yes, but in a lot of other ways the answer is no.
As I said earlier, this deck’s ramp and mana are
well-constructed, which is good as Temmet is the
sort of card that’s going to work better when the
deck has mana to play him plus something else
in a turn. The token-generating suite is okay,
and actually contains some pretty high-quality
stuff, but there are fewer cards that
create a lot of small zombie tokens than I’d like.
Creating 4/4 tokens is cool and all, but Temmet’s
design heavily incentivizes pairing him with lots
of small creatures, so the bigger tokens with more
rigorous requirements to be created simply feel
out of place, even if they’re more aesthetically
fitting. Even more problematically, this deck
doesn’t have much of the sort of bursty draw that
pairs best with Temmet. There isn’t a lot of draw
overall, and a lot of the draw that is here isn’t
great for taking advantage of Temmet’s ability.
There isn’t a reliable way to sacrifice Corpse
Augur, nor any good way to let Midnight Reaper
or Undead Augur translate into Temmet Triggers,
and you’re not gonna tap down your zombies
to Cryptbreaker if you want to swing in that
turn. Most of the other draw options are mana
expensive, so you’re looking at 10 mana minimum
to do a Temmet + draw maneuver. The one thing
working in Temmet’s favor here is the half-dozen
or so cycling cards in the deck, but at that
point you’re paying five mana for the commander
plus two mana to cycle during the combat step
for roughly an Undead Warchief worth of anthem.
The final problem is this deck’s interaction
suite. It has 10 cards that perform a removal
role in some way or other, which might work
for a faster zombie deck, but I’m not sold on
this deck’s ability to win quickly. Worse, it has
very little protection and no counterspells—a blue
deck that’s vulnerable to removal and board
wipes runs no counterspells. C’mon. I dunno,
this deck isn’t unplayably bad or anything, but
it fails to meaningfully commit to any of its
subthemes, and with the way it’s currently
built its command zone feels arbitrary
at best, just a generic zombie guy that gives
the deck its colors. It is a bit more cohesive
when we look at the visual presentation, with
a clear emphasis on Amonkhet-style zombies, and
there’s certainly some admirable effort put into
new art for a lot of the cards present. I don’t
usually treat these as product or value reviews,
you know, I’m much more interested in the deck and
the sort of experience that Wizards of the Coast
is handing to a newer player who is pulling this
out of the box to play a game of commander with,
but I’ll make a minor exception here. As a product
there is a lot going for this, and if you are a
zombie player who’s looking for a bundle of good
zombie cards plus some cool new arts, this
absolutely might be a great purchase. Just
don’t buy this if you’re looking for a cohesive
deck out of the box, because this is not that.
With all that said, I still want to try an
upgrade for this. When I first saw this precon, my
immediate thought was that it’d be cool to morph
it into a Hashaton deck. But honestly, this deck
is so far from enabling Hashaton well that I’m
inclined to stick with Temmet instead and see what
we can do with 15 swap-outs to try and actually
let him feel like a legitimate commander. So
let’s do that, and I’m going to start by talking
about what I’m cutting. Binding Mummy and Twisted
Abomination aren’t great in general, and I’m also
going to cut a couple discard payoffs that just
aren’t adequately supported here. Sorry Hashaton.
Beyond that, Maskwood Nexus seems out of place
here, and I’m also going to cut out a handful of
zombies that are just a bit mediocre. This deck is
a rare Gravecrawler L—with no sacrifice, this
card just doesn’t really do anything. Nothing
beyond these particularly offends me, but I
will trim a handful more mediocre cards just
to make space for better support—these are cards
that are just on the weaker side mechanically,
or which don’t tie in particularly well with
the gameplan I’m trying to cultivate. For our
additions, the first order of business is that
I want to add a bunch more draw and filtering,
since they do double duty in smoothing out the
way this deck plays and making it punchier with
Temmet. Keep Watch, Distant Melody, Pact of the
Serpent, and Raffine all allow the deck to give
its zombies a massive pump-up for a reasonable
amount of mana. In addition to these, I’m
choosing to add three cards for protection that
can also draw cards, which are Change of Plans,
You Find the Villains’ Lair, and Your Temple Is
Under Attack, and these are nice because of their
flexibility. The other major thing I’m choosing to
add is cards to create zombie tokens, three total
in this case. Syphon Flesh and Dark Salvation both
provide removal and token generation, and Endless
Ranks of the Dead is a good singular zombie token
maker. Honestly there are a bunch of other zombie
token generators in the $5-10 range that I didn’t
add due to price, and if you’re really trying to
build a good Temmet deck you should probably go
find some of those. Varina stands out as a card
that is absurdly good in a Temmet deck, performing
both key tasks I’m looking for at a good rate.
For a few final additions, Diregraf Captain is
just a generically good zombie, and I’m basically
having it replace a couple zombie-typal cards
I’m cutting. Lethal Scheme is a removal spell
that also includes a good amount of draw/discard
filtering, and it’s easily payable with black
zombie tokens. Felwar Stone and Ponder are here to
give some extra ramp and filtering respectively,
just smoothing out the overall gameplan. The last
addition is Cephalid Coliseum, a land that can
provide a burst of draw triggers at a great rate
at a point in the game when the deck is looking
to close things out. Through these changes my hope
is that Temmet will more consistently be useful,
sticking around longer and providing larger
buffs to zombies. The addition of some more
zombie tokens and removal will hopefully also
direct the gameplan of the deck in the right
direction. Temmet definitely isn’t my favorite
commander, like there’s definitely less depth
there than with the alternate commander Hashaton,
but I still can’t help but respect the attempt at
making a different sort of zombie deck, one more
based around drawing and discarding than around
death triggers and sacrificing. Hopefully we see
more exploration in this direction in the future,
and hopefully future zombie precons end
up a bit more coherently constructed.
Announcement! I have a PO box now, and the address
is on screen. Feel free to send me your favorite
card or a handwritten poem proclaiming your love
of Brushwaggs. The PO box isn’t wildly large, so
don’t send me anything bulky as there is a solid
chance it will be thrown away instead of finding
its way to me. This should go without saying,
but please also don’t send me anything dangerous
or disgusting. Thanks! If I get enough cards I
might turn them into a deck or make them into
a video of some sort. Delicious future content
for the gaping, content-hungry maws of the world.
With that said, thanks for watching, and thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel. I’m a
fan of Archidekt’s UI, a thing which was
on screen for basically the whole video,
and an especially nice feature for tweaking
decks is the maybeboard categories, which let
me keep thoughts and card additions nice and
organized. A link to my upgraded precon list
is in the description. I also want to thank
my patrons for their support, some of whose
names are on screen now. I’ll be doing a Q&A next
week, so if you want to submit questions for that
and/or watch it, you can sign up for $3 a month
at the link in the description. Alright, bye now.